Olha essa aqui que me deixou de cara.
Será que sua roupa limpinha pode estar
danificando o seu fígado? Pois é, acabou
de sair um estudo mostrando que aquele
cheirinho característico de roupa que
volta da lavanderia a seco pode ser um
sinal de problema sério. O culpado é um
produto químico chamado
tetracloroetileno
ou simplesmente PCE, que é usado há
décadas para limpar roupa sem água. Os
pesquisadores analisaram mais de 16
pessoas e descobriram algo assustador.
Quem tinha esse produto no sangue
apresentava três vezes mais chance de
desenvolver fibrose no fígado. E olha o
detalhe interessante, pessoas com renda
mais alta tinham níveis maiores da
substância, justamente porque eu uso
mais lavanderia a seco para roupas,
cortinas, tapetes e estofados. O pior é
que esse químico não tá só na
lavanderia, viu? Aqui no Brasil ele
aparece removedores de mancha, alguns
adesivos e até produtos de limpeza
automotiva. Por isso que hoje você vê
muito produto com selo livre de
solventes colorados no rótulo. Então
fica a dica, sempre que possível,
prefira lavar suas roupas em casa com
água e sabão. E se precisar usar
lavanderias a seco, deixa rouparejar bem
antes de guardar no armário.